sumemos 536 398 quiero que lo hagamos de
dos formas diferentes para que entiendan
realmente de qué se trata esto de llevar
primero lo haremos de la forma más
tradicional empezando con las unidades
cuánto es 6 + 8 sabemos que 6 + 8 es
igual a 14 6 + 8 igual a 14
y lo escribiremos acá debajo en la suma
el 4 va en el lugar de las unidades más
una decena que va en el lugar de las
decenas y ahora nos enfocamos en las
decenas una decena más tres decenas más
nueve decenas que resultado dar veamos
una más tres decenas más nueve decenas
es igual a trece decenas
como son 13 decenas el 1 va de verde
otra forma de verlo es estas son tres
decenas y una centena dirás cómo es
posible acuérdate que estas son decenas
al estar sumando una decena más tres
decenas más nueve decenas en realidad
estamos sumando 10 más 30 más 90 y esto
nos da 130 así que ponemos el 30 en el
lugar de las decenas como un 3 el 3
representa el 30 y ponemos este 1 en el
lugar de las centenas
10 decenas es igual a 100 y ahora
sumaremos las centenas tenemos una
centena más 5 centenas más tres centenas
esto es igual a 1 566 y 39 centenas no
olvidemos que esto vale 900 un 9 en el
lugar de las centenas en realidad esto
es
una centena más 500
cinco centenas
+ 300
tres centenas igual a 900
nueve centenas es exactamente lo que
tenemos aquí en la suma 100 más 500 más
300 es igual a 900 y terminamos esto es
igual a 934